welcome to the David Pakman show I'm
fairing cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today lots
of news to talk about there's actually
been several developments with several
different gubernatorial candidates
throughout the United States but let's
start once again with my home state of
Florida the nation's capital of crazy
Ron DeSantis the Trump backed Republican
nominee for governor in the state of
Florida just one is primary Tuesday
night and then Wednesday went and made
the biggest possible gaffe you could
imagine here it is how do you plan to
beat him well look I mean this is a
florida elections are always competitive
and you know this is a guy who although
he's much too too liberal for Florida I
think he's got huge problems with how
he's governed Tallahassee you know he is
an articulate spokesman for those far
left views and he's a charismatic
candidate and you know I watched those
Democrat debates none of that it was my
cup of tea but I mean he performed
better than the other people there so so
we've got to work hard to make sure that
we continue Florida going in a good
direction let's build off the success
we've had on Governor Scott the last
thing we need to do is to monkey this up
by trying to embrace a socialist agenda
with huge tax increases and bankrupting
the state that is not going to work
that's not gonna monkey this up now in
case you're not aware obviously very
strong racial overtones in that phrase
and his opponent is Andrew Gilliam who
happens to be the very first African
American candidate put forth by a major
party here in the state of Florida for
the office of the governor so he's
running against an african-american then
oops a 40 and slip accusing the man of
potentially monkeying things up now to
their credit and this was actually kind
of shocking Fox News did come out later
and said hey we do not agree with the
language that he used this is now what
we want to represent DeSantis later on
tried to clarify and say
see I was using that turn of phrase you
know the the phrase that means it messed
something up the phrase you're looking
for is muck this up in you CK to muck
something up what you said however was a
very racially charged statement now in
the 24 hours that have passed since
DeSantis made this gaffe we have had all
kinds of right-wingers ben shapiro did
an article about how this wasn't racism
it was a simple slip of the tongue a
stupid thing to say and to all of those
people who say that no DeSantis wasn't
intentionally being racist it was you
know he just thought that that's what
the phrase was after direct you to
another story that actually broke right
around the same time that DeSantis was
on television using that racially
charged phrase the American Ledger News
Group uncovered the fact that Ron de
santis is actually a moderator for a
far-right tea party group on Facebook
that has about 95,000 members and in
this group they spread racist ideas they
push conspiracy theories here's just a
couple of things in this group that Ron
de santis is an active moderator for
they called black lives matter activists
ghetto scum they have made fun of the
Parkland survivors they claim that what
happened in Charlottesville was a hoax
and if you go to the actual story on the
American ledger they're screenshots
there they've got Rhonda Santa's name on
there as the official moderator and all
kinds of racist statements conspiracy
theories all right you know queuing on
type stuff going on on this Facebook
page of which Ron de santis is 100% an
active participant so to all of those
people who say that no I do not think
that Ron de santis was trying to be a
racist with that comment
you need to go back and look at this
man's history look at what he's been
doing online look at everything that has
his name on it this was not a slip of
the tongue
this was not an oops I thought that was
the phrase type situation that man knew
exactly what he was doing because he
understands what he's up against
he knows that for I think what 24 years
now here in the state of Florida we have
had solid Republican rule nothing in
this state has gotten better we're
slashing funds for environmental
protection we're in the middle of one of
the worst toxic algae outbreaks in the
state's history we're letting oil
drillers come in destroy the Everglades
which is a major tourist attraction
that's how we bring money into the state
wages are down losing jobs the sugar
industry's polluting like crazy down in
South Florida paying off all the
politicians to make sure they never get
held accountable yeah things aren't that
good here in the state of Florida Ron so
if you want to accuse somebody of
monkeying it up I suggest you look at
what the GOP has done to this state over
the last 24 years and while you're at it
go ahead and get a book of you know
sayings and quotes so that you don't
screw the next one up accidentally but
again I don't think there was any
question in this man's mind as to what
he was saying there and it flowed out of
his mouth so easily so naturally he knew
what he was doing he knew what he was
saying and he knew what the the backlash
was gonna be but he also knew given the
context of it that this would be
something that he would be able to
easily write off and that's what he's
attempting to do now but luckily with
this story coming out from the American
ledger showing that this is actually
what this man has participated in in the
past gonna be hard for him to overcome
this one but luckily the voters in the
state of Florida unfortunately tend to
forgive and forget and they'll go for
anybody no matter how crazy they are
that's how we got eight years of rick
scott